cuando tenemos una función de varias
variables digamos una f que depende de
equis y quizás muchas otras cosas verdad
en realidad esta función toma varias
variables de entrada y digamos que esta
función tiene un solo un número de
salida en verdad de algo algo muy común
que solemos hacer con este tipo de
bichos verdad es tratar de buscar un
valor máximo para esta función es decir
estaríamos tratando de maximizar nuestra
función vamos a tratar de maximizar
nuestra función verdad qué significa
esto bueno significa hallar digamos los
valores de xy quizás las otras variables
de entrada para hallar todas estas de
tal suerte que nuestra función f o la
salida bajo f es tan grande como sea
posible y esto aparece digamos en la
práctica todo el tiempo verdad porque
por lo general no no sólo jugamos con
estas funciones de varias de varias
variables solo por por hacer trucos y
derivadas y demás verdad en realidad
estas funciones pueden significar varias
cosas por ejemplo
opción que puede significar es que la
función f tiene la interpretación de que
sean ganancias de una empresa verdad
donde las variables pues podrían ser
distintas podría ser los salarios de
cada trabajador
quizás el número de trabajadores los
costos digamos de la materia prima si
estás haciendo algún producto quizás la
deuda que vas a adquirir para invertir
en fin puede tener muchas muchísimas
interpretaciones verdad y esencialmente
tenemos técnicas para encontrar es los
valores máximos que puede alcanzar esta
función y los veremos enlaces en los
próximos vídeos verdad
otra otra digamos interpretación que
podemos darle a esta función y que de
hecho tiene gran relevancia en los
estudios de inteligencia artificial
verdad es cuando asignamos una función
de costo a alguna tarea que realiza la
computadora la computadora entonces
vamos a asignar una función de costo
verdad donde por ejemplo a lo mejor le
estamos queriendo enseñar a una
ahora vamos a entender un audio o quizás
a leer un texto entonces lo que tratamos
de hacer es hallar una función que diga
qué tan mal lo está haciendo cuando hace
un intento entonces si diseñamos bien
esta función verdad entonces lo que
necesitaríamos es minimizar la función
de costo verdad es decir minimizar la
función de costo es decir hallar una
forma de tal suerte que la computadora
sepa que no lo haga tan mal verdad o que
lo haga lo mejor posible así que muchas
cosas en inteligencia artificial se
reducen a hallar digamos una función de
costo que quizás no es una tarea fácil y
después tratar de aplicar técnicas que
que veremos en los siguientes vídeos y
dejar que la computadora trate de
minimizar esa función de costo pero no
sólo que que lo haga de esta forma en
realidad mucha investigación se ha
enfocado en lograr que estas técnicas se
realicen de forma rápida y eficiente y
antes que nada primero vamos a tratar de
pensar que significa hallar el máximo de
una
de varias variables y aquí del lado
izquierdo tengo una gráfica de una
función de dos variables es decir
tenemos una entrada en un espacio de dos
dimensiones y la salida esencialmente es
la altura en la gráfica de la función
verdad es un número y si queremos
maximizar entonces tendríamos que hallar
el pico más alto en la gráfica de esta
función ya que hemos hallado el pico
ahora buscamos la entrada en el plano xy
verdad debajo del pico es decir esto
sería la entrada que maximiza la función
verdad entonces como podríamos hallar
esta entrada bueno la observación
fundamental aquí es pensar que si
tomamos un plano tangente en el pico
verdad aquí aquí podemos ver el plano
este plano será paralelo al plano xy y
si lo hiciéramos digamos no sé quizás en
otro punto digamos en algún otro lado
cercano donde no hay un máximo si el
plano está inclinado que es lo que nos
dice esto bueno pues nos dice que si nos
movemos ligeramente en la dirección de
la inclinación del plano
podríamos aumentar el valor de la
función y si no hay digamos si no hay
pendiente de este plano es una señal de
que si nos movemos en alguna dirección
en realidad no va a aumentar
considerablemente su valor su altura
verdad ahora la pregunta natural es
bueno y esto qué significa en en
términos de fórmulas verdad entonces
aquí tendríamos que recordar cómo hallar
los planos tangentes para eso te
recomiendo que chequen los vídeos que ya
hemos desarrollado en khan academy sobre
este tema así que si pensamos en la
pendiente digamos en la dirección x aquí
podemos ver esa pendiente y pensamos
también en la pendiente en la dirección
y pues entonces ambas deben ser cero
verdad ambas se tienen que anular así
que lo que requerimos es que la derivada
parcial de f con respecto a la variable
x verdad por supuesto en el lugar en
donde alcanzamos el pico más alto verdad
digamos en el punto x 0 0 necesitamos
que esta derivada parcial se anule
verdad y lo mismo debe ocurrir para la
derivada parcial de la función con
respecto de i
exactamente en el mismo punto x 0 y 0
esta derivada parcial también debe
anularse verdad y ambas deben anularse
porque si vemos de este lado verdad si
imaginamos digamos que estamos caminando
en la dirección de ye sobre el plano en
realidad no estamos aumentando nuestro
valor verdad la pendiente en este caso
sería 0 es decir la derivada parcial
respecto de 10 sería 0 pero si nos
movemos en la dirección de x verdad
entonces vemos que nuestra pendiente es
negativa porque porque si disminuimos al
aumentar el valor de x esto no implica
que pequeños pasos sobre la gráfica hará
que la altura disminuya verdad en esa
dirección
así que si vemos estas dos ecuaciones en
realidad tenemos un sistema de
ecuaciones donde buscamos hallar los
valores de x cero ig-0 que satisfagan a
ambas ecuaciones
que cumplan ambas ecuaciones ahora solo
porque se cumplen estas dos ecuaciones
no implica que ya hayamos el máximo solo
es un requisito pero si buscamos digamos
por ejemplo en los pequeños picos que
tenemos alrededor de este gran pico
verdad en realidad en todos ellos su
plano tangente también sería paralelo al
plano xy verdad de hecho es por esto que
a todos estos picos se les conoce de una
forma muy particular y se les llama
máximos máximos locales
locales y esto qué significa bueno
esencialmente son máximos pero en
realidad lo estamos pensando respecto a
los vecinos de este pico verdad no no lo
estamos pensando con respecto al resto
de la función porque respecto al toda la
función en realidad sólo tenemos un
máximo digamos que podríamos llamar
global podríamos también tener otra
circunstancia qué pasa con los puntos
mínimos por ejemplo de este lado vemos
un mínimo global y aquí tenemos
alrededor algunos mínimos locales verdad
que serían justamente como los picos
pero invertidos cierto entonces lo que
significa o digamos lo que implica es
que si tratamos de minimizar la función
esto nos dice que necesitamos cumplir
este mismo requisito de las dos
ecuaciones de que las dos derivadas se
anulen para encontrar mínimos así que el
trabajo en realidad no acaba simplemente
hallando los puntos en donde las
derivadas parciales se anulen sino que
necesitamos considerar más criterios
para poder verificar si son máximos o si
son mínimos locales verdad
entonces esto que tenemos aquí de forma
simplificada se puede expresar de la
siguiente forma nosotros sabemos que el
gradiente de la función el gradiente de
la función es un vector que recopila
toda la información de las derivadas
parciales verdad por ejemplo tenemos la
derivada parcial respecto de x la
derivada parcial la derivada parcial de
f con respecto de ye y quizás así
tenemos más variables pues tenemos más
derivadas parciales cierto entonces este
es el vector gradiente y nosotros
podríamos decir que esto de acá arriba
es igual al vector cero verdad es igual
al vector que tiene puras componentes
cero muy bien es es la misma forma de
decir esto verdad pero con una anotación
en vectores y de hecho una forma más
compacta es considerar a este vector de
digamos donde todos sus componentes son
0 como el vector 0 ya algunas personas
lo denotan como un un cero en negrita
cierto entonces esencialmente de forma
de digamos de forma compacta buscamos x
0 y 0 de tal suerte que el gradiente de
la función en ese punto igual a 0 muy
bien al vector 0 y en realidad hacemos
esto para ocupar menos espacio en la
práctica pues de todos modos tenemos que
calcular las derivadas parciales igualar
las a 0 y tratar de resolver el sistema
de ecuaciones pero la idea detrás de
todo esto es que el plano tangente es
paralelo al plano xy y ya vimos que en
realidad no basta con esto para
determinar si el máximo mínimo verdad
puede que sea cualquiera de los dos pero
además en cálculo tenemos otra
posibilidad es digamos puede ser un
lugar en donde el plano sea paralelo al
plano x pero que en realidad no se vea
ni como un máximo ni tampoco como un
mínimo local ya ese tipo de puntos los
conocemos como punto silla pero bueno de
estos puntos ya hablaremos en el próximo
vídeo